[Music]
Wayne Brady channeling a legend the
actor paid tribute to the life of Little
Richard Sunday night during the Beatty
Awards in a performance from his home
the iconic singer passed away from bone
cancer earlier this year he was 87 Brady
honored the legendary career by
performing several of his famous hits
[Music]
ba-ba-boom ET spoke with brady about
honoring the architect of rock-and-roll
but I know how much of an honor it was
for you for them to ask you to perform
the tribute to Little Richard and I know
what this means to you to do it right so
just kind of talk about that and talk
about how you wanted to approach this
this performance when people kid I think
they'll see and I was just lecturing my
my daughter remaining on being a being
an entertainer being a showman which is
a little different sometimes than if
then then if you're being an actor in a
venue like this you are being a
performer and a showman people just like
the sing song sometimes Little Richard
just didn't sing a song as the architect
of rock and roll as the innovator as the
originator he created this art form that
was born out of it was a frenetic energy
that there's a reason that when you
heard the first bit of Lucy this is his
voice it it like did this and went all
down is true so I wanted to treat this
performance it just wasn't like oh
Wayne's gonna sing a song Little Richard
was an innovator and lil and Little
Richard was extra yeah he was extra
before we knew the definition of oh you
extra absolutely I wanted to put
together a show in my house that showed
oh this is a tribute to him and all that
he was in his grandiosity and his
musical prowess and the Verve and the
sex and the rock that you got from it
and the fun so that's what what what we
did because you know it's it's a little
daunting
you're on an award show with all these
amazing black performers uh sure
you know a little break you break down
the performers I'm right on the ushe I'm
like how do you compete for space with
Usher and I did that by just being me
and doing what would I do when I learned
by watching the greats like little
Little Richard so I hope that I was able
to even transfer just
just this much this much of fun and love
into that show
[Music]
[Music]